the disturbing video comes from the
inside of an emergency room and the
woman screaming a burn unit nurse who is
being arrested by a Salt Lake City
police officer the incident captured by
police and hospital cameras happened in
July but now the district attorney says
he wants a criminal investigation
University of Utah nurse Alix wubble
says she was just doing her job
following Hospital protocol by refusing
to let police take a blood sample from
an unconscious patient nope wubble says
detective Jeff Payne demanded a blood
sample from a car crash victim who was
in a coma and severely burned his truck
smashed by a car racing from police
according to local media Bob Wills
calmly explains the policy for obtaining
blood she even gets her supervisor on
the phone who backs her up the tension
only escalates she's the one that has
told me no okay no we're done we're done
you're under arrest
we'll go we're done Salt Lake City's
police chief apologized and said what
happened was unacceptable I was alarmed
I want to be very clear we take this
very seriously we're now wobbles isn't
filing a lawsuit I feel very strongly
and giving people the benefit of the
doubt and I surely believe that he was
honest in his apology and sincere and
his willingness to try and make change
and make things better police release
wobbles without charges that day after
she sat in the police car for 20 minutes
detective Payne said in a written report
that his watch commander advised him to
arrest the nurse for interfering with a
police investigation
hey another officer on administrative
leave
as internal investigators looked into
this startling incident dan Simon CNN
Salt Lake City